Where in the States, most support for the arts comes through private donors,...
...through charities and through corporate sponsorship.
And here, you have something quite unique in the UK which is the public funding of the Arts and there's public subsidy.
The National is subsidized by the UK taxpayer.
And what that allows it to do is to keep ticket prices very low and accessible,...
...so people can still come to the theater and see some of the greatest actors in the UK for ten pounds.
You just couldn't pay that on Broadway, it wouldn't exist.
So, it allows the National to do incredibly risky work but at a level of quality, of professionalism,...
...which you wouldn't see anywhere else.
Today is the second camera rehearsal for our broadcast of Nation.
Nation is a really dynamic show and one that we're really excited to do because it's our first live matinee.
And it's the first time that we construct to engage a children's audience, a family audience.
The amazing thing about having such strong public support for the arts...
...is that it sends out a message to audiences, to people, that the arts are important.
The US doesn't have a national theater.
So, there are lots of places, I would argue, in America where it doesn't reach all the people.
And the fact that the UK has this building which sits right in the heart of London,...
...on the South Bank where millions of people are walking by,...
...there's a real sense of this theater being a hub.
And I think it stands as a kind of symbol to what the arts means in this country.
That the arts is for everyone, supported by all the people.
And that it is an incredibly important activity which enriches the life of everyone in this country.